Thank You general Vanessa welcome to the
show thank you glad to be here now why
is it that Wells Fargo finds it so
important to support chess here in st.
Louis well it's really important for
Wells Fargo to support chess in st.
Louis because we have a very important
imperative in our philanthropy to
support education one of our four focus
areas is arts and culture and by
supporting the World Chess Hall of Fame
here in st. Louis we get to not only
support that but also ensuring that our
young people are learning strategic
thinking skills and growing both
socially and academically is Wells Fargo
involved in the education side with
helping with Cheston schools actually I
say that and now realized that a couple
years ago I did an appearance for Wells
Fargo in a school I forget the name of
the school but I remember going to a
school that should I was teaching chess
to a lot of kids yes we actually provide
robust support to both public private
schools across the st. Louis area we
have a specific focus on st. Louis
Public Schools as well do you play chess
no I need to learn yes my husband plays
I have a son who just turned four last
week and I'm going to make sure that he
plays there are a lot of Grand Master's
rolling around we'll be lighting up to
teach those kids how broad is the
support when you talk about being in all
these schools first of all actually let
me ask you a different question isn't
warm your heart to see these kids
playing chess you get a chance to go in
and well and see some of these kids over
it definitely warms my heart not only
because it's a wonderful sport to play
but the skills that kids learn while
playing chests are important for their
life and you know selfishly from a
talent perspective we need folks in our
business being you know investors and
looking at ways to build wealth to think
strategically to creative problem solve
and so not only are they connecting with
others but the skills that they're
learning will serve them well in their
careers for years that's a fantastic
point can we count on wells fargo
support over the next five ten years no
we don't make long-term commitments
gorgeous chess with long-term plan all
the time
we are going to support education for a
very long time and chest is definitely a
part of that well we appreciate your
time here Vanessa Sara Foster cooksey
thank you so much for joining us and
keep up the philanthropy work thank you
guys so much support in the air in the
st. Louis area for chess and it
continues amazing place